[Music]
in the late 1920s a young man outside
Tampa in Florida picked up an axe and
hacked his family to death his name is
Victor lecarter at that point cannabis
was not illegal in the United States and
a man called Harry Anslinger had taken
over the department of alcohol
prohibition just as alcohol prohibition
was ending so he inherits this huge
government department that's just lost
the war on alcohol it's riddled with
corruption and he wants to keep it going
he had previously said that cannabis was
not dangerous shouldn't worry about it
he suddenly decided that cannabis was
the most evil literally this is his
world's most evil drug in the world he
said it was much worse than heroin he
said he said if Frankenstein's monster
met cannabis on the staircase it would
drop dead of fright and he latched on to
the case of Victor lecarter with the
help of the kind of fox news of his day
which was called the Hearst Newspapers
he announced that Victor lecarter had
smoked cannabis that's why he'd cut his
hacked his family to death with an axe
and this is what will happen if we allow
cannabis to spread I mean he to ban and
prohibit cannabis it was in the wake of
that case that cannabis is banned years
later somebody goes back a researcher
went many years later decades later a
researcher went back and looked at
Victor lo Carter's files there's no
evidence he even smoked cannabis his
family had been told he needed to be
institutionalized a year before he was
severely mentally ill but they decided
to keep him at home the origins of the
war on drugs which I wrote about in my
book chasing the screen the first and
last days of the war on drugs
overwhelmingly looked like that if you'd
asked me when I started doing the
research potassium screen why was
cannabis banned I would have guessed
they'd would have given the reasons then
but if you stopped someone on the street
now they would give you no we don't want
kids to use drugs we don't want people
to become addicted what's fascinating is
that stuff just never virtually never
came up when they were banning cannabis
right or indeed the other drugs it was
overwhelmingly a kind of racial panic
and absurd history is about about what
was going to happen now the one thing
you can say in defense of the war on
drugs and the war on cannabis and
particular is we've given it a fair shot
right the United States has spent a
trillion dollars its imprisoned more
people than any other country in human
history including Stalin's Russia and
males China
it's destroyed whole countries like
Colombia at the end of all that we can't
even keep drugs out of our prisons where
we pay someone to walk around the wall
perimeter the whole time which gives you
some idea of how well we were ever going
to keep their out of a country with two
three thousand mile borders there is an
alternative for how we can think about
cannabis there are places that have
legalized cannabis and we can see the
results so I spent a lot of time in
Colorado in Washington State I actually
spent time in places that have legalized
other drugs heroin for example has been
legalized in Switzerland with
extraordinary results there have been
zero overdose deaths on legal heroin in
Switzerland in the more than 13 years
since they says they legalized but with
cannabis specifically again we can see
the results when you ban cannabis
several things happen the first thing
that happens is it you will have noticed
it does not disappear its transferred
from licensed legal businesses to armed
criminal gangsters those armed criminal
gangsters have to operate differently to
a licensed business so you know you will
have noticed the head of Budweiser does
not go and shoot the head of Heineken in
the face right your local liquor store
does not send people to go and stab
people in the local bar right exactly
that happened under alcohol prohibition
right I mean exactly that and it ended
the day alcohol prohibition ended why
because when you ban drugs they have to
operate in an illegal market where
there's no and I learned this from lots
of drug dealers I spent time with for
chasing the screen not just for fun
that's some fun in it as well and the
the an illegal market can only operate
through violence right you have no
recourse to the law if you're if if I go
out of here now and I try to steal a
bottle of vodka you know the liquor
store will call the cops the cops will
come and take me away so there's no need
for that liquor store to be violent to
be intimidating if I go out of here now
and try to steal a bag of weed from the
people who sell it not so far away they
can't call the cops right cops would
come and arrest them they have to fight
me now you don't want to be having a
fight every day if you're a dealer so
you got to establish a reputation for
being so frightening that people
wouldn't be so stupid as to come and
fight you right
so this is the ratchet effect you get
with prohibition you create a market
that can only be regulated by violence
and where there is actually a premium on
being the most violent person and the
most intimidating person well you have
to be violently intimidating to protect
your market now when you legalize that
goes away immediately there it ended
where is Al Capone it does anyone even
know the head of Smirnoff's name right
everyone watching this knows Al Capone's
name
I bet nobody watching this knows the
head of Smirnoff name what changed it's
not the drug it's the fact that it went
from being illegal and therefore
controlled by gangsters to legal and
being controlled by legal and licensed
businesses the second thing that happens
which is a slightly more wonky point but
I think is really interesting and
important is that milder forms of the
drug disappear so you often get people
say well we can't legalize cannabis
because the cannabis people use today
isn't the cannabis people used in the
1960s right it's much stronger it's
things like skunk and super skunk that's
true and it's entirely the product of
cannabis prohibition you want to
understand why I got in something just
before alcohol was banned in the United
States most popular drinks by far were
beer and wine after alcohol was
legalized again most popular drinks by
far were beer and wine as they remain
today
and when our call was banned you
couldn't get hold of beer or wine
anywhere most popular drinks were
whiskey and moonshine you think well why
is that why would banning a drug change
the form of the drug is probably kind of
rather prosaic reason imagine we had to
smuggle enough you know alcohol for your
local bar from the Mexican border or the
Canadian border right if we fill our
wagon with beer we'll get drink for a
hundred people if we fill our wagon with
whiskey we'll get drink for thousands of
people when you ban drugs there's
suddenly a premium on getting the
biggest possible kick into the smallest
possible space because it's got to be
smuggled right it's got to be
transported in secret this happens with
all drugs this is why cannabis become
has become much more potent the most
popular form of consuming cocaine prior
to it being banned was in tea coca tea
and you may remember a drink called Coca
Cola that really did contain exactly
what it sounds like they don't exist
anymore
don't you ever hear about coca tea right
Coco Karl it resists but it's not what
it was obviously and most popular way of
consuming opiates
by far was a drink called laudanum and
something called mrs. Winslow's soothing
syrup it was a small traces of opiates
right again they disappear most popular
form becomes heroin when you ban a drug
only the most extreme force of that drug
become available now now most people who
smoke cannabis don't want skunk right
just like if I go into bar around the
corner from here today probably very few
people who can be drinking vodka and no
one's going to be drinking absinthe
right if you're concerned about the more
extreme forms of the drug which I think
we should be with cannabis because there
is it's not a huge relationship but
there's some relationship with
dysfunctional behavior and then you want
to put a really high premium on getting
milder forms of the drug available to
almost all the users who want it right
so that's another effect that happens
with legalization and you know one of
the things that's so moving everywhere I
went but they'd move beyond the war on
drugs from Portugal where they
decriminalized all drugs to Switzerland
where they legalized heroin for addicts
to Uruguay and Washington and and
Colorado where they legalized cannabis
the pattern was always the same it is
super controversial at first and
understandably people are really worried
and then they see the effects it's not a
silver bullet there's still problems but
there's such a significant improvement
that the support massively rises so 55
percent of people in Colorado voted to
legalize in 2015 today 70% of people
support it governor Hickenlooper who
opposed it now says it works really well
they've had a huge increase in tax
revenue I interviewed one former police
officer who told me a story about this
that really stayed with me one day in
the 70s he was staking out a dealer in a
car park in Wayne in New Jersey in plain
clothes and a kid came up to him and
said hey mister will you go into that
liquor store and buy me some booze I'm
not allowed to I'm too young it was like
a 12 year old or something
and he said no get out of here what he
talked about get out of here so the kid
walked over to the drug dealer and
bought some drugs from him instead and
he had this kind of Epiphany he's like
oh actually legalization a legal
regulated system puts a barrier between
children and drugs that does not
currently exist if you're a parent who
doesn't want your child to smoke
cannabis and if you're a parent you
shouldn't because there is evidence that
it
can impair development for teenagers you
want to put a really high premium on
getting cannabis out of the hands of
armed criminal gangs you don't care
whether the customers are 13 30 or 80
and getting into the hands of licensed
legal regulated businesses who have
something to lose this is why in
Colorado all the research shows there's
been a really significant fall in cartel
and organized crime activities as they
legalized there's been a fall in
teenagers using it was already quite low
but it's fallen there's been a massive
increase in tax revenue you know it's
not perfect there were some things I
would have tweaked in the Colorado
legalization but you know you can tweak
a legal market would I have any power of
an illegal market there's nothing we can
do about it right at some point that the
president of Switzerland Ruth Dreyfus
when she made the case to the Swiss
people for legalizing heroin and she's
one of the great heroes of I've ever met
in my life she explained to them you
know when you hear the word legalization
you picture like anarchy and chaos what
we have now is anarchy and chaos you
have unknown criminals selling unknown
chemicals to unknown drug users all in
the dark all filled with violence right
legalization is the way we restore order
to this chaos at some point we have to
look at the results it's worked
incredibly well and let's look at the
places that are maintaining a criminal
war on cannabis how was that working out
for you
[Music]